anna is with us in Miami Florida hey
Anna how are you how are you better than
I deserve what's up in your world okay
so in October my husband and I were in a
car accident everybody's fine I'm the
insurance paid for all the repairs but
we're and that someone we were at fault
and we just received a notification that
we might be getting sued because we were
underinsured so baby step two and we
were scheduled to be out of baby
substitute this month at the end of the
month we have about have the last three
thousand dollars and we're going to send
to the car payment so your your your car
insurance was not enough to cover the
other people's car or medical bills
medical bills apparently it's one of
those lawyers that just tried to get
more money and we were very underinsured
and we went to Financial Peace
University and we knew better and it
just kind of you didn't take care of it
on time and so what what is the amount
that you think you're facing I am Not
sure all our insurance is going to cover
up to fifteen thousand which was our max
and placement of their car or is that
medical right the bodily injury was 50k
okay that's what I'm checking all right
and so above 50k was this a really bad
wreck why do you think the person was
hurt that badly or do you think there's
an ice dam not at all I think it's
they're trying to just scan I guess
gotcha
okay all right here's what I would do
then as you finish up baby step two
you're gonna finish up finish up this
month we have money to send this will be
great the last payment
then what I'm gonna do is just pile up
my emergency phone as fast as I possibly
can you may be facing the emergency of
hiring an attorney but my guess is that
based on what you're saying if this is
what if it comes down to the fact these
people are just trying to get money you
don't have any money they're just
checking to see if you've got money
piled up over there in a corner that
they can grab from you once they realize
there's not any to get number one number
two they realize you're going to fight
back
that is your best defense now and so
you're going to hire an attorney to
advise you something like this and we
don't have they can come after your
income but that's the but not the point
the point is you're going to use your
income to hire an attorney to not give
these people money that they are not due
if they're trying to scam you in other
words I'm going to fight now if they
legitimately are hurt you should want to
do something to try to fix them it's
your fault right but if they're just
after some money they think there's
money on the table here you know they're
walking around wearing a neck brace and
they're not hurt then that's you know
that kind of stuff and I don't know
what's going on but that's what your
suspicion is that fifty thousand should
have covered this wreck the medical on
this wreck and you know a what if a
reasonable person sat down at your
kitchen table and showed you that they
were you know fifty seven thousand
dollars worth of medical bills you'd
probably write them a check for seven if
you had it or do it shortly you know and
but but and you looked at the bills you
know that that's I get that okay but if
they're just saying hey I think I'm
gonna hire ambulance-chasing attorney
and go after these people then what I'm
gonna do there is I'm gonna hit them
hard fast and often when the mouth and
I'm gonna hire an attorney that so mean
I don't even like him right okay go
ahead and pay off the car that's yeah
yeah you mean you're there you're there
this month finish it off now
you use your income and very quickly
build your emergency fund and I don't
mind if it even gets a little bit larger
not to give them a target to shoot at
but for you to hire an attorney with
another quick question if you don't mind
taxes and we were about to pay zero have
to save about $3,000 and the tax
protects persons they recommended us to
put to max out our IRAs no you don't
need your tax person deciding what
you're going to do you know what you're
supposed to do you're not ready to max
out I raised you don't have your
emergency fund built and you're facing a
lawsuit okay you don't make sense your
IRAs and that's why would you need a
pile of cash right now you need a war
chest because we're getting ready to go
to war that's what it sounds like to me
that's the way you're describing this if
it's something different than that then
it's something different than that but
that's based on what you told me